today on Fox & Friends you all watch Fox
and Friends sure don't like just yeah
sure that felt like the air going out of
a giant pudding today on Fox and Friends
President Trump was interviewed and he
was asked about his presidency and he
said this is a quote I don't think any
president has done what I've done that's
what he said yeah yeah then Bill Clinton
called in and said if you're talking
about stormy Daniels I hate to break it
to you
in an interview President Trump said if
he were impeached if he were impeached
everyone would be very poor now after
hearing this Mike Pence said not me I'd
get a promotion he's got to be a little
excited Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
is gonna make his fourth trip to North
Korea it's a news story yeah yeah I'm
payoffs adapt to the last couple of days
I'm not going there to negotiate I'm
going to defect he wants to North Korea
is looking like a good place to hang out
right now yes stress-free here's a story
it's not about politics a drone a drone
flying over the Amazon rainforest
discovered a tribe that has never had
contact with the outside world
yes that's amazing yeah okay that was
three weeks ago now every member of the
tribe is addicted to fortnight every
single one that's all they do
yeah Arizona Police I love this story
found an old tunnel once used to smuggle
cocaine from Mexico into a KFC yes
across the border and into a KFC
customers at that KFC said you know they
did get your order out pretty fast
you
you